folks  he doesn't benefit from saying this  this doesn't help his earnings like you  know how some people are supposed to say  real estate's going to do very good and  they're in real estate  uh real estate's not this is just you  know  not going to happen nothing's going to  happen in real estate and your  son-in-law is in real estate you're  trying to protect this business so he  keeps growing because people are  watching you  but real estate's going to go through  this  if somebody said oh let me tell you  something it's don't even worry about it  everything's going to be all right and  it's in your benefit to get everybody to  think everything's going to be all right  if you own tesla and you're shorting  tesla  if you say i think tesla's going to go  out of business and they're not going to  do good because elon musk is not a good  ceo  you have incentive you have a motive  behind it you're shorting tesla  he doesn't benefit from this folks  that's jamie dimon